- On this episode, I get really
deep on that last question.
Don't fast forward!
(upbeat hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this episode
201 of The #AskGaryVee Show.
Alright, we're in to the 200s.
Monday morning,
feeling good about that.
DRock doing some
snaps over here.
We're taping a DailyVee today.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- [Gary] Which I'm
very excited about.
You're not filming right now.
'Cause we got this, right?
If you want to take a quick
little sample, you'll do that.
India, great to see you.
Is that a San Francisco Giants?
- [Staphon] I told you.
- What?
You guys were
debating about that?
- [India] I was like,
"Should I wear it?"
- That's really cool, I like it.
- [Staphon] She was
like "He won't notice."
I was like, "Yes, he will."
- I noticed.
India, are you
ready for the show?
- I'm ready for the
- [Both] Show.
- Call in show was a lot of fun.
I enjoyed that,
I want to do that.
I think we have some
things to figure out.
Andy!
I really wish this was a call in
show but I feel like we didn't
have time to talk
about the kinks.
- Yeah.
- I feel like there's kinks.
- For the call in?
Yeah, we'll work them out.
It'll be easy.
- But I think 202 or 203
I want to do it so
I want to address kinks.
- Okay.
- Alright.
So we are now into the next
frontier episode 200 to 300.
You know, I'm really curious
how long I'm actually
going to do this.
I don't feel it
wavering, don't worry.
But I do think, I would say I
was positive I'd get to 200
I'm not positive I get to 300.
I can see us doing something
weird and being at 267
being like that's it.
I really do believe that.
Alright.
- [India] 267?
- 267, we'll all
be watching that.
(laughter)
Alright, India,
let's get into the show.
- [Voiceover] The Wealth Life
asks, "How do you deal with
people who don't
keep their word?"
- Wealth, I'll be very honest
with you I think one of the
great secrets of my business
success and life in general is
zero expectation of others.
I know that a lot of people get
mad at me when I say that
in my life, in my business life,
when I say it in public but
it's my truth.
I'm just not that devastated.
It's a data point.
People don't keep their
word all the time, India.
As a matter of fact,
it's probably a thing I struggle
with the most in being
the CEO of this company.
A lot of people have worked in
other places where the person
hasn't kept their word and
they're cynical to my word.
And listen, by the way,
I haven't kept my word
my whole life.
Even now because something
may fall through the inbox.
Like, you see
what's going on now.
Right?
I know that I promised to give a
shoutout or a birthday wish and
I miss it.
There's human error in not
keeping your word and then
there's just not keeping
your word which happens often.
It's a reality,
humans are flawed.
And I would tell you that the
biggest differentiation between
myself and many others if I'm
self-evaluating that has been a
big deal for me is
I just don't cry.
There's no crying in business.
How do I deal with it?
I move on.
I collect data.
I'm like, "Oh, Staphon doesn't
keep his word very often
"so his word is not as valuable
to me so I'm going
"to take it with a grain of salt
"that he's going to
actually link this up."
Whatever it may be, I think
it's something that you know,
I don't like entitlement.
And I do think believe it or
not, I do think that people get
upset with others from a
level of entitlement more than
anything else.
Like sorry, Rick.
Sorry, Wealth Wellness,
Wealth Life sorry that
entrepreneur life
let you down and
didn't post that thing.
It is what it is what it is.
I just let stuff
roll off my back.
It is what it is.
I'm just prepared
for the negative
and so I'm completely unfazed by it.
I'm like,
"Oh, that was intriguing."
Not like, "Oh, screwed me.
I've been sabotaged.
"I failed because India didn't
come through with her word."
"Ogilvy screwed me."
It's business.
Put on your pants.
Your big boy, big girl
pants and get to work.
I contextualize it.
I use it as a data set for my
next business behavior with that
individual or organization
and I just move on.
And, I don't dwell
and I go forward.
People slow themselves down.
- [India] Ready?
It's good.
Really good.
- Thanks, it's true.
It's true.
It's the game, I'm sorry.
People are going
to let you down.
People are not
going to come through.
Almost nothing turns
out the way I want it to.
It's the ability to adjust to
that that separates winners and
losers in the business world.
- [India] From Justin.
- Justin. Timberlake?
- Yes. Justin Timberlake.
- This is Justin Timberlake?
- No.
- [Gary] Bieber?
- [India] It's whatever Justin
you want it to be right now.
- Okay.
- [India] Bieber or Timberlake.
- Neither. I'll tell you later.
- [India]
- Novello.
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] Justin asks,
"If you were building a retail
"biz from the ground up,
what trend would you
"be paying the
most attention to?"
- Justin, this is
a silly question.
All of them.
What do you mean "what trend"?
How people are shopping on
mobile, how bricks and mortors
are still very viable.
Health and wellness,
meditation, technology.
There's no one trend
to pay attention to.
I'm not going to give
you, there's no secret.
There's no episode 201 maybe
Gary will answer my question and
give me some incredible insight.
They're all in play.
All the trends matter,
mobile commerce, people shopping
behaviors, real time delivery
and then all the genres of
things you could
be selling, right?
Just a million things that
people are in to like tea and
yoga pants and I don't know.
This question is kind of
exhausting and I'm not mad at
you, Justin Novello, it's just
it's a silly question
because they all matter.
I pay attention to everything I
can as much as possible, Justin.
As many things as possible.
They're all data sets, they
all can lead to opportunity.
You know, that's what I
would pay attention to.
There's a million
things going on.
There are 75 different pillar,
core things that are
going on in retail.
The lack of people
traveling to malls.
Postmates same-day delivery.
Downtowns and cities
emerging again and
the gentrification
of neighborhoods.
Fashion trends.
What people are
drinking and eating.
Sneaker swag.
Accessories on cell phones.
Everything that's happening in
Asia that one out of every seven
times happens in the US.
Like, I don't know, all of it.
- [Voiceover] Melita asks,
"If we aren't good with numbers,
"can we really be
good at business?"
- I'm shit with numbers.
Next.
- [India] Perfect.
From Andy.
- Andy.
- [India] a video.
- I'm not that shit with
numbers but I'm very average.
- What's up, Gary?
This is Andy_Barton.
Staphon, link it up, here
in the Teton in Wyoming.
I know you say you don't want to
climb that god damn mountain but
how do you think nature effects
your brain and do you take time
to get outside?
Thanks for everything.
- Andy, great question.
Beautiful setting.
I do like videos.
Good job, India for picking
one, I do want more videos in
beautiful places.
Andy, this is one.
Look, nature is not at the
forefront of it for me but I
think a lot of people use it.
I have a ton of
entrepreneurial friends who
rock climb, run marathons.
I had a meeting this morning
with Mark Evans that you'll see
in DailyVee, he's running
40 races for
his 40th birthday year.
That's how he escapes.
And that's how he keeps his
mental health and I think nature
is an incredible,
incredible driver for so many.
I'm so thankful for
nature in many ways.
Obviously, what it is in society
but from a business stand point
I've watched entrepreneur after
entrepreneur after entrepreneur
really get enormous value from
walking trails to surfing.
It's incredible.
It's not my
thing, it's just not.
I really don't care
about pretty sunsets.
I have no interest in ever
going on a mountain trail.
I have just none.
Beautiful fields are
not interesting to me.
I would be like, "Oh, we
could build homes here
"and make money."
It's not who I am but that
doesn't mean that it doesn't
bring enormous value to people
and I watch a lot of people here
go to the mountains even a lot
of people that work at Vayner
love working in L.A.
and San Franscisco 'cause
they provide so much of that.
I've watched the New York crew
do the best they can in to the
Upper Westchester or the
Vermonts or the Maines
or things of that nature.
They're all probably getting
pumped because we're getting
that time of year where
nature plays a little bit
of a bigger role.
So many get so much value,
even look at the body language
of these three,
like it's awesome.
iI's just not how I escape.
I escape really in weird ways.
I escape with the Jets.
The Jets matter so much
to me that's how I escape.
And the truth is I work out,
obviously, seven days a week now
as you guys know.
I'm doing a lot of that indoors.
So I don't know.
I'm just not drawn to nature.
I've never been.
Mother Nature and I
have respect but not love.
- [India] Last one.
- Yeah.
- [Voiceover] "This is Vignesh.
"I am 15 years old.
"My question is whenever
someone puts you down,
"how do you push
yourself back up?"
- Vignesh, you know, it's
tougher when you're 15 as you're
building your self esteem and
your foundation of your life.
Listen, if you're 45 or 62,
there are so many people right
now that are not doing what they
love because they're worried
about what other people
think or what other people say.
Especially your inner family.
We've talked
about this at length.
I'm very passionate about this.
I'm so grateful I don't give a
crap about what anybody thinks
of me while equally caring.
It's incredibly important to me
what India or DRock or
Staphon think of me.
It's incredibly important.
It's stunning though how
anti-establishment or how much
I would push back
when they would try
to impose their will on me.
And that's a very
important differentiation.
Actually, that's one of the
first time I've ever articulated
this way and I like this.
There's a very big difference
between what one thinks of you
and what one tries to do
by imposing their way on you.
I'm very open, empathetic
and quite self-aware of what
everybody thinks of me and pander
to it, react to it and adjust to
it but for somebody to try to
impose their way on me without
knowing me is just
super not interesting.
And so, I was able to navigate
through junior high and
high school and really not
struggle with peer pressure.
I just, very honestly, thought
I was better than everybody.
I didn't act that way.
If you go find all the kids that
went to high school with me
I don't think any of them would
say that I walked around like
I was cooler than them.
That would have been very hard
as a 4 foot 11 freshman that was
being made fun of
for not being 5 foot.
It's how I thought inside
and I think there's a lot of
intestinal fortitude to use a
gorilla monsoon term,
that's when wrestlers would beat
up and they would fight like the
Hulkster and Macho Man
and Ultimate Warrior
that was the whole kind of
genre of the 80s, get beat the
crap out of and then all of a
sudden and so,
that's kinda how I am.
I can take a lot and then
all of a sudden fight back.
There's nothing other I can
say than you're 15 now,
when you're 51 or when you're
91 you're going to be stunned
how little you care.
How little it mattered and this
includes your parents and your
siblings and even your children.
This is an intense thing,
this is a very intense thing.
But if I could wish anything
besides health on people
there's a lot.
I say this saying a lot.
There's a lot of traits I like.
Self-awareness but man there's
unbelievable happiness that
comes along with self-belief and
recognizing how this plays out.
And let me tell you how this
plays out, Prince as he was
taking his last breath, as a big
shout out to Prince,
I'm a huge fan,
I don't think Prince cared what
Billboard Magazine said
or what anybody said.
It's just the way it is.
It's the way it is so if through
this plea on this show, on 201,
on a Monday in late spring,
if four of you to understand,
if I could get four
of you to understand
it's just not going to matter
when people I mean...
I love when people...
I don't even know
what else to tell you.
I'm going to say it very clear.
Staphon get very focused here
because I want to really
deliver this with all the
drama that it deserves.
I like when people put me down.
I get off on when
people put me down.
Nothing is more interesting
to me than to prove
all of you wrong.
I love the people that think I'm
a huckster or I got some hidden
agenda or I'm not that good or I
won't be that great or I think
too big of myself or my dad had
a liquor store and that's the
only reason I'm
successful or I got lucky or
da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Show me.
Please, please, please continue
to judge me and underestimate me
because it's the only driver I
have and that's how I'm wired.
And I don't expect all of you to
be wired that way but if I can
through my energy move any of
you and trust me I'm reading your
comments 'cause your
comments are my oxygen and
I see so many of you.
So many comments over the
last three or four months of
people saying I've got a little
more cockiness or
confidence than I used to.
As a matter of fact,
I see it in you guys.
I truly see my inner circle
have more confidence,
it just rubs off.
India, you're getting cocky.
- [India] I probably am.
- [Gary] Have you felt it?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- I think it's confidence.
- [Gary] I know, I know, I know.
But it's true, right?
There's a rub off.
It's kind of like a
leader on a sports team.
It rubs off.
One of the great accomplishments
in my life will be the fact that
I was able to rub off my
confidence not only on my
inner circle but on the
community that decided to.
It's unbelievable how good I
feel that I get to reward the
amazing reward that you give me
which is in all the things you
could be watching right
now you're watching this.
In all the things you could be
reading, spending time on, time,
you've decided to watch me. Me!
Do you know how incredibly
empowering that is and
it's at scale?
It's not three people.
Do you know how
empowering that is?
And for me not only knowing I
can give you tactical advice or
in a funny way that I answer
question number three a girl in
Indonesia might say if GaryVee
is bad at math and has been
successful I can too.
Or in this ending rant you can
care a little bit less what your
coworker or your older brother
or that naysayer says or what I
know so many of you deal with
which is the trolling and the
hate and the disagreeing even
when it's done well and I love
when people disagree with me in
the comments section I take it
for what it is.
Even when that happens...
You know how pissed I
was at DailyVee 030?
How many people like were
emphatically were drilling me
for a bad episode?
Fine but after all that and
that's fine and I agree and we
didn't do a good job setting
that up and I don't think I set
up DRock for success.
It's a genre that he's not
as passionate about.
I could have done a better job.
I understand that but it blows
me away of how much venom people
can put like
after you provided...
You're only as good
as your last at-bat.
200 great episodes of a business
show, 30 great episodes of a
docu show, 5,000 fucking
interview of business stuff,
unbelievable engagement,
answering your questions,
answering your snaps.
Boom, one baseball fantasy thing
pure and utter disagreement,
disparagement, hate,
negativity, that's hard.
I'm the most confident and it
felt bad and I didn't like it.
So what do I expect from others?
I get it but it is what it is
and at the end of the day it's
not gonna matter and you have
to love yourself first and
feel good and complete with
yourself first so as a 15 year
old I would do what I did as
a 15 year old which is start
building those skills and not
listen to your parents and not
listen to your teachers and
not listen to your friends.
Respect it but don't let
anybody, anybody impose their
way on you. It's you.
You're with yourself and
you've got to make
yourself happy first.
Good, right?
- [India] Inspiring.
- You're inspired?
- [India] Mhmmm.
Thanks, India.
DRock, were you inspired?
- Eh.
- [Gary] You're so used to it?
- I'm just kidding. Definitely.
- Real cynical, right?
See what happens.
- [Staphon] Confidence.
That's what it is.
- No, it wasn't confidence.
You see what he just did?
He just did exactly what I said.
Right, you two are switching.
Alright, great.
That's it, right?
Question of the day.
What should I ask?
What are you, you guys
interested in anything?
India are you interested?
Actually, India, you and DRock
get to ask the question of the
day I'm not passionate about it.
Start with DRock.
- [Gary] Alright, tough guy.
(laughter)
- [India] Mine's a stupid question.
- [Gary] It's alright you
got a lot of time to think.
- What was your favorite
episode of DailyVee? Why?
- [Gary] Ooh. And why?
That's a good one because
DRock wants some qual data.
India?
- I want to know who your
baseball team is and
who you root for.
- Alright.
Awesome, you're in
a baseball mood.
Guys, thanks for
watching 201,
ooh 201 it's like
the next grade.
Isn't that how they
do it in college?
101, like Econ 101, Econ 201.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(upbeat hip hop music)